jim irsay from yesterday talking about
their
efforts to find a new quarterback now
that philip rivers is retiring
and talking with chris and frank and
myself
our beliefs is we're close we have a
tremendous nucleus of players
that are capable of competing for the
super bowl very soon
so ideally if you can get
someone to come in this year and several
years after who is ready to go
it gives you your best opportunity
and you don't have as much of a
maturation
aspect of seeing them uh develop and
and and get to that level that they need
to get so you can
uh get to a super bowl and win it
look he's made it clear first of all i
love that chair can i
i have i'd like to know where he got the
chair i wouldn't like to know how much
he paid for the chair but that's a hell
of a chair
uh they they clearly want to plug and
play veteran yeah they don't want a
rookie chris ballard said
something not that long ago that made it
clear they're not looking at a rook he
said you don't just draft a quarterback
you gotta draft the right one back right
they want a proven commodity because
they have a team that's a proven
commodity exactly you've got some
veterans on that team that that
are going to say wait a minute wait a
minute you had all these other
these proven quarterbacks out there and
we got to break in a rookie and we don't
know whether or not he's going to be any
good no
no thank you so i think that makes sense
and i think matthew stafford makes the
most sense for the indianapolis
i i me too and especially the way they i
mean the way frank wright calls plays
it's an aggressive down the field
passing game
that fits matthew stafford and you know
to everything you just said
you're right the team's in place they're
they're in the window right now
they're they're there like it's not
crazy to think oh wait the 2021 super
bowl
the indianapolis colts got in if they
get a real good quarterback i mean the
offensive line's good
the wide receivers are good the running
backs and tight ends are really good
you know the defensive line's good yeah
maybe they could use a legit pass rusher
linebackers are awesome
secondaries good yes they could use
another
real legit cover corner in my opinion
but there we just went through the whole
team and we only mentioned two positions
of need really
so they are there they're ready for
prime time ballard has built something
reich's systems in place i do think it
fits stafford
and if i'm stafford that's definitely
one of the teams i got starred that's on
my radar
jim irsay also talked about andrew lucky
said that andrew knows we would love to
have him back i don't really know if
we'll see that you know
of all the guys who have retired um
surprisingly and prematurely the big
name guys barry sanders calvin johnson
luck is the one that would be most
likely
to come back after a year or two off
this is now two years that he hasn't
played
i don't think he's ever coming back and
i think if he does come back
it would probably be with another team
anyway i don't i don't i just don't
think he's ever coming back i think when
he decided he was done he's done and he
seems like the kind of guy who isn't
going to change his mind but
you know he can still change his mind
five years from now and get himself back
into shape
and come back and give it a go and i'm
sure teams would be interested because
what would he be
35 probably so what you got guys playing
into their 40s yeah yeah it's just
it's it's you know even for guys as
awesome as andrew luck was taking that
much time off
you know at that position especially uh
i i you know we haven't seen that that
would that would be tough
i'm with you i think it's he's checked
out physically mentally he had had
enough of the sport and i don't think
we're gonna be hearing from again
and also like to you said too like you
know if you're
the colts i mean that ship's gone it's
done you know
again i think there's guys in that
locker room that probably are gonna be
like man
why he quit on us two years ago i don't
want him in here as our quarterback now
that that wouldn't be the best look
either for that locker room so
uh i think it's all all done for andrew
luck
you know we had heard last year that tom
brady expressed some preliminary
interest in the colts irsay admitted
they looked at brady but they preferred
frank wright's familiarity with philip
rivers i also believe
that there was an element of
we don't want to put ourselves in
another josh mcdaniels type of situation
where we think we're getting brady
and our interest in brady is what wakes
the patriots up to throw a bunch of
money at him to keep him from coming to
us
because of that whole deflategate thing
and just the the bitter rivalry between
the two teams
i think the colts didn't want to touch
the hot stove again after getting burned
by josh mcdaniels
yeah i i don't doubt that you know i i
don't um
i i mean again it's tom brady i don't
think it's just just because he was with
josh mcdaniels that means he's gonna do
the same thing or anything like that
i think at the end of the day it just
came down to two things you know
siriani and frank wright's relationship
with philip rivers that pushed him over
the top siriani was there
in with the san diego chargers rivers
had done really good things there
in that 12 and four year uh and of
course now you know frank reich being
the head coach there i think more than
anything it was that but i heard the
same rumors too at the time that the
colts were
you know at least doing their homework
on tom brady yep
well and i think the colts at the time
were were maybe hoping for a short-term
bridge with the idea of developing a
younger quarterback i think now they're
looking for a longer
bridge they just decided that philip
rivers isn't the bridge they wanted to
continue
to utilize or he decided to retire or a
little bit of both
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports